[Música]
el expresidente de donald trump solicitó
un tribunal federal que impida que el
fbi revise los documentos que incautó en
su casa de florida hasta que se designe
un abogado independiente que los revise
tenemos reporte desde washington
en argentina la fiscalía pidió 12 años
de prisión para la vicepresidenta de
cristina fernández por defraudar al
estado cuando era mandataria entre 2007
y 2015 el caso podría tardar años
mientras la ley der agota instancias de
apelación
y el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador aseguró que no habrá
impunidad para los criminales en la
desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa esto tras la detención del ex
fiscal jesús murillo karam por el caso
de 2014
estas son las noticias de américa en
france 24 comenzamos el equipo legal del
ex presidente de eeuu donald trump
interpuso una demanda contra el fbi por
el allanamiento reciente a su residencia
de mar al lago en el estado de florida
de esta manera mientras el proceso esté
en curso el fbi no podrá continuar
analizando las pruebas confiscadas en su
residencia hasta tanto el juez asigne un
agente neutral para revisarlos
previamente nos daba los detalles
nuestro corresponsal en washington
cristóbal vázquez
en la demanda trump y su equipo legal le
pide al departamento de justicia que
detengan la revisión de los documentos
que fueron allanados en la mansión del
expresidente de la florida la mansión de
mar a lago song se queja de que
inicialmente el proceso de allanamiento
tuvo que haber en este proceso tuvo que
haber un abogado del expresidente
presente para saber qué exactamente
salía de la mansión el expresidente y su
equipo legal también dicen que en caso
de que no se pueda parar inmediatamente
esta revisión de documentos por parte
del fbi y entonces que se nombre a un
agente especial que acompañe esta
revisión de documentos que está haciendo
el fbi estos documentos que según el
departamento de justicia son altamente
clasificados y aquí habrían entonces
precisamente líos legales para el
presidente varios medios de comunicación
le habían pedido y le han pedido a la
justicia norteamericana que por favor
publiquen los detalles que de lo que
exactamente encontraron los agentes del
fbi allá
y hasta este jueves tiene plazo
precisamente la justicia para redactar
los documentos de los detalles que se
encontraron en mar al lago para que esta
información se haga pública a través de
los medios de comunicación que la
solicitaron inicialmente así que este
jueves era bastante importante para
conocer más detalles de lo que ahí se
encontró de lo que se encontró en la
mansión de mar a lago
la fiscalía de argentina pidió 12 años
de prisión para la vicepresidenta de
cristina fernández por el caso conocido
como vialidad en el que se investigan
presuntas irregularidades en la
adjudicación de obras públicas cuando
era presidenta el ministerio público
también solicitó la inhabilitación de
por vida de la ex jefa de estado para
ejercer cargos públicos con paulo lucumí
tiene más información la fiscalía de
argentina pidió 12 años de prisión para
la ex presidenta y actual vicepresidenta
del país cristina fernández de kirchner
además que sea inhabilitada de por vida
para ejercer cargos públicos por los
presuntos delitos de asociación ilícita
entre 2007 y 2015 cuando ocupó la casa
rosada- esta parte solicita se condene
a cristina elisabet fernández a apenas
12 años de prisión inhabilitación
especial perpetua para ejercer cargos
públicos accesoria legales el pago de
las costas por considerar la autora
penalmente responsable de los delitos
socialista agravada por su calidad de
jefa y de administración fraudulenta
agravada haber sido cometida en
perjuicio de administración pública que
concurren de manera real la fiscalía
denuncia que se habían desviado mil
millones de dólares al año a través de
más de 50 contratos de obras entregadas
al empresario lázaro báez condenado a 12
años de cárcel por lavado de dinero
fernández de 69 años ha defendido su
inocencia y ha denunciado una
persecución política por parte del ente
judicial según ella orquestado por la
oposición de derecha e instruido a mi
abogado para que a los efectos de poder
ejercer efectivamente mi derecho a
defensa en juicio solicite la ampliación
de mi declaración indagatoria para la
audiencia del día de mañana 23 de agosto
en los últimos años fernández ha sido
salpicada en varias investigaciones
independientes entre sobornos lavado de
dinero y obstrucción de la justicia en
el reciente procedimiento iniciado en
2019 y que había sido suspendido por la
pandemia del cómic 19 no se conocerá una
decisión del tribunal hasta finales de
2022 los cocaleros y la policía
boliviana se enfrentaron nuevamente en
la paz e intercambiaron gases
lacrimógenos y bombas caseras las
protestas que comenzaron el primero de
agosto se habían desactivado gracias a
una mesa de diálogo pero se rompieron
nuevamente la semana pasada llevando a
los productores de la hoja de nuevo a
las calles las manifestaciones se
derivan de una disputa prolongada entre
dos grupos de productores de coca los
productores de los yungas que tomaron
las calles de la paz y un grupo de
cocaleros respaldado por el gobierno y
encabezado por arnold de alanís los
yungas exigen al gobierno que cierre lo
que consideran un mercado ilegal de coca
en méxico el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador aseguró que no habrá
impunidad para quienes participaron en
la desaparición de los 43 estudiantes de
ayotzinapa el comentario tiene lugar
cuando méxico presenta una alta tasa de
impunidad por parte de la justicia y
tras la detención de jesús murillo karam
ex fiscal general de la república y
primer funcionario de alto nivel
relacionado con este caso que es
detenido
tras la detención del ex procurador
general jesús murillo karam por su
presunta participación en el caso de los
43 estudiantes desaparecidos de la hilux
y napas el presidente andrés manuel
lópez obrador aseguró que no habrá
impunidad para las personas culpables y
que el estado ha dejado de ser el
principal violador de derechos humanos
se pensaba
qué
quién es
cometían delitos
en nombre del estado
gozaban de impunidad
y eso
ya se terminó
la prisión preventiva de jesús murió que
fue impuesta para garantizar su
comparecencia en una audiencia judicial
del miércoles donde se determinará si
será juzgado por cargos relacionados con
el caso
el grupo de expertos encomendados por la
comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos para estudiar la desaparición de
los 43 estudiantes solicitó este lunes
acceso a todas las pruebas del informe
que presentó la semana pasada al
gobierno
se va a dañar se va a manchar
del ejército
o las fuerzas armadas no
si se mancha
sí
hay complicidad
cuestionado sobre la posibilidad de
detener al ex presidente enrique peña
nieto el mandatario andrés manuel lópez
obrador indicó que la fiscalía general
de la república o los jueces
determinarán si hay otros involucrados
y seguimos en méxico porque el
periodista freddy román fue asesinado en
el chip al 5 la capital del sureño
estado de guerrero previamente los
detalles nos los daba nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico mario
carbones
este lunes fue asesinado en chilpancingo
en el estado de guerrero el periodista
freddy román director fundador y editor
del semanario la realidad quien también
colaboraba en distintos medios locales
con el asesinato de freddy román suman
ya 15 los comunicadores que han perdido
la vida en distintos ataques tan solo lo
que va del año en el país
apenas dos horas antes de su asesinato
freddy román había publicado su última
columna titulada crimen de estado sin
culpar al jefe y que hablaba sobre el
reciente informe sobre el caso
ayotzinapa la organización artículo 19
ha reportado que en el primer semestre
del año en méxico ha habido más de 300
ataques a periodistas y medios de
comunicación es un ataque cada 14 horas
el crimen contra el periodista de
guerrero se da apenas un día después
desde la oficina en méxico del alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos expresará que el
asesinato de periodistas en méxico es
motivo de seria preocupación para el
organismo internacional
freddy román había recién abordado su
vehículo a las afueras de su casa cuando
fue impactado con armas de fuego ya se
investiga el crimen por parte de las
autoridades locales
y para el cierre fueron reveladas dos
nuevas imágenes del telescopio espacial
james webb que retratan júpiter con sus
tormentas gigantes y vientos extremos la
calidad de las fotografías permite ver
que las auroras se extienden a grandes
altitudes sobre los polos norte y sur
del planeta entre otras cosas se aprecia
la gran mancha roja una tormenta de
arena que según la nasa es tan grande
que podría tragarse la tierra
siga con nosotros en france 24
[Música]